Instead of applying a texture to a surface we can apply a texture to represent
the world itself. In the distance are clouds in all directions. The way this
illusion is done is with a sky box. The idea is to put the viewer in the center
of a box and put the environment on the walls, floor, and ceiling. Doing this
reminds me a bit of The Truman Show, where Truman's world is highly limited and
he runs his ship into, well, I don't want to spoil anything if you haven't seen
it. The key is that you have to be careful to not let the viewer get too close
to the sky so that he doesn't figure out it's just an illusion. If I turn on
the wire frame for the cube, the trick is revealed. You can see the walls of
the box. Without the wire frame, the illusion is seamless. If the viewer moves
around, the center of the box moves with them. In this way, there's no
distortion as the view of the walls never changes. This type of texture is
called a cube map. It's made of six images that form the cube faces. The viewer
is always placed at the center of the cube. For example, here's the frustum for
the top of the cube, the plus Y face. The cube shape is not required. It's
possible to have other geometries, such as a hemispherical dome around the
scene. Whatever the shape, our eyes can't see the Z buffer, so can't tell the
sky is only, say, 100 meters away. Sky boxes are typically used for star fields
or, well, the sky, for times when you're not near the ground. Alternately, you
can simply make the surrounding sky box a part of the scene such as shown here.
Real geometry has the advantage that it can receive shadows from the object.
The main rule is that you want to make sure that nothing pokes through the
walls of the sky box itself. Oh, and one more thing, you definitely want to set
the far distance of your camera so that it encompasses the sky box itself,
otherwise it will be clipped out.